tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo mio
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo tornati
su io sono pane che un titolo della
madonna primi tre ragazzi ad un certo
casinò di roba tra l'altro anche starci
wars che sarebbe una roba tipo parodia
di star wars non molto tempo fa in una
galassia neanche tanto lontana e non è
affatto ufficiale chiaramente una
parodia comunque dai lasciamo perdere
vabbè dovrebbe essere una parolieri di
star wars è una cosa c'è yo yo ma no
vabbè episodio iv una nuova pagnotta
dopo la distruzione della pompa di
benzina le ultime in prigione della
flotta a livelle voce che ha scritto
stecco lord brioche le inarrestabili
forze di lord brioche si ragazzi il
futuro della grazia dipende da
quest'ultimo scontro è bene non avevo
veramente dubbi chi è che ha fatto aim
brad di sargiano simulator ragazzi io li
amo li adoro c'è uno stendino che sta
attaccando una pagnotta cioè io come si
fa non amarli reca come cos'è è una
razza sono un toast c'è anche il boss
per la madonna mi attaccano cazzo via
ecco perfetto stato mi stavo schiantando
come un idiota già subito perfetto mai
così ci siamo ragazzi sono la tosta
navicella e bellezza
ma perché no vabbè ragazzi la cosa più
[ __ ] che io abbia mai visto questo ci
facciamo delle collette per fare le
statue ei creatori di aim brad perché
dio mio
l'unico problema ragazze che non so
guidare anche se tv ma baffa nku lo
schianta pil 0,4 secondi che mi ha dato
il brevetto diverso e questo non c'è la
patente è una roba a 3 ecco la to ride
lui dimostra soltanto la tragedia che
devo fare devo resistere tipo sei minuti
a sta roba
ma siete serie no comunque quella che
non lo sapete ma da piccolo io quando
ero piccolo giocavo al gioco di guerre
stellari che era identico era uguale
praticamente fantastico non capire un
cazzo perché a furia di girare così non
capivo dove era il boss dovrà l'alto per
ok credo che il mio nemico ragazzi sia
lo stendino non la pagnotta quindi
[ __ ] devo distruggere cose tipo
questo eccolo eccolo che disagio che
cos'è sta roba
a cosa sto giocando legami oddio c'è io
musica epica mentre sto comandando un
toast con dei razzi nel culo è la cosa
più c è veramente reputo la mia vita
completa lega non so che cazzo dire è
bellissimo ok ok luridi vasta eccolo lì
perfetta ragazzi si ha a cuore
non so guidare gun io non sono un toast
ma dai ma decisivo sentite st cagate al
casinò quindi facciamo merde merde di
toast niente niente niente niente perché
non so guidare madonna che non so
guidare manco le bici sul mio test non
c'è la nutella star demi che si sono
schiantati tutti in un secondo per
cambiando traiettoria ogni 4 secondi e
un genocidio madonna sono schiantati
tutti dietro di me per noi mi eccito
tutti vivi so io sono io sono io non so
guidare non a schiaffi a schiaffi in
faccia
sì c'è si sono affatto ragazzi ce l'ho
fatta ha distrutto il ferro da stiro
sono un toast se il mio di organ 12 ore
per far staccato assurdo cioè
impossibile premi barra spaziatrice
grazie è e cosa è pupa con gray appalti
gli scherzi sono voglio provare la corsa
dei bug e restano hanno aggiunto un
miliardo di cose in due giorni a da
scuse sono una ciambella devo fare una
cosa sono morto cioè la cosa più senza
senso che potessero fare per ryan brad
c'è ma cos'è sono una ciambella va beh
complimenti brava brava così sopra la
mannino sulla padella ma chi se ne frega
ragazzi citazione 2015 by fa vigenti una
ciambella la mattina si sveglia e inizia
a correre
l'importante non è essere la ciambella o
del pane
l'importante è alzata affanculo
[Musica]
no o mio dio oddio il muro se cadi ti
ammazzo la famiglia che ovviamente
saranno tutti i ciambellini di un
sudatissimo possiamo continuare questa
corsa incredibile perché non ci posso
credere
ero arrivato alla fine ero arrivato ero
arrivato alla fine ma sei serio ci ho
messo due minuti e 30 per fare una roba
di tre secondi da fermo madonna preso a
coltellate fino a far uscire il ketchup
di giuro giu
ma come devi entrare in questa cosa ce
l'ha poi fa dio mio no ce la puoi farà
piegarti piegati come si piega tua madre
allora sentita trt dai piegati si piega
anche tua mamma bravo bravo bravissimo
12 anni per fare sta cosa e quindi non
dovevo entrare qua dentro
spiegatemi cosa devo fare della mia vita
adesso ma era solo una roba di tempo
quest anno fa non capito sentite lascia
cinque minuti per arrivare qua 5 cosa ho
fatto
ho fatto una roba etica ma sono morto
subito dopo non vogliono iniziare solo
prevedere quanto ci metto per arrivare
fino alla fine solo per questo tempo
parziale 5 minuti e 20 sì o leggermente
mancato il tavolo ma proprio un po
sporca la vacca la [ __ ] non tutte le
ciambelle escono col buco
neanche tua mamma vero che cazzo fai
balli il valzer
[Musica]
sei minuti dopo che ho fatto sta roba
voglio rifarla un secondo prevedere cosa
quanto ci metto al bravo bravo bravo
piano mi sta risucchiando gli alieni
cos'è sta roba
cos'è non son petardo a caso sono
ciambelle col botto ragazzi sul nuovo
tipo di ciambelle che si servono cose
troppo lento ma dai non l'avrei mai
detto che sale l'ufo nell'ombra del muro
[Musica]
ragazzi lo voglio giocare di nuovo solo
per vedere quanto ci mettono perché è
stato orribile
ah si mi butto giù l'ultima non devo
fare il check point giusto che mi
buttavo subito sul tavolo e [ __ ]
ok bravo bravo così meno di un minuto
voglio voglio ridere o le eccolo eco
piano piano piano che può che è
bravissimo 43 secondi al posto di 6
minuti e 25 perfetto fate vedere se
riesco a fare qualcos'altro perché dio
mio e la cosa fiori allora sentite e la
cosa più stupida che alla quale io abbia
mai giocato in tutta la mia vita però
allo stesso tempo e geniale ragazzi
adesso in avanti le facciamo le maratone
di ciambelle le facciamo noi ceniamo per
strada buttiamo le ciambelle vediamo chi
vince alzati e cammina con le ciabatte
forza ok i tricks il trick softco la
ciambella perfetto ci ha messo meno di
prima
un topo c'era un topo ho investito un
topo ragazzi maltrattamento di animali
finti va bene non si può dire perché la
di dai cazzo il giorno dopo lega
facciamoli tutti a sto punto perché
tanto dura non pene mi mette ansia
quando parte i ragazzi mi sembra peggio
di una gara di valentino c'è una roba
adrenalinica al massimo che lo
attaccarmi al muro pure cioè non ti
basta al fatto che sono una ciambella
per attaccarmi al muro ma attacca tuo
fratello
bra e ci riesco pure quello che mi
spaventa uno skate no era lì sopra li
mortacci suo nome lo rifaccio a livello
piuttosto mi scalo le vere ma non me lo
rifaccio di questa volta attacchi al
alla porta nel vero senso della parola
ma che certo a ciambella per attaccare
napoli ancora dai mio dio se cadi ti
uccido la famiglia
madonna è rischiato ha rischiato tua
madre l'ho vista che rischiava piangeva
bravo 4
aridaje questi minuti è una roba mi sono
attaccato al cazzo dove mi sono
attaccato dove non vedo un pene ok ma
devo fare un salto che mi chiamo coso
salvatore questa volta ce l'aveva anche
mia nonna aveva uguale quando ero
piccolo giuro ecco l'avevo rotta anche
in modo uguale a te possino ammazza ok
ok 18 bravo allora ho fatto tutto un
percorso chilometrico
sia lodato il cielo o questa luce che
qualsiasi cosa sia perfetto sei minuti e
4 secondi ragazzi sono un pro della
madonna
non c'è dubbio at least infine a baffa
il giorno dopo ragazzi stiamo per
finirli tutti sti livelli in europa
atroce ma ce la sto facendo bagno che
poi tanto ragazzi sono tutti livelli che
ho già fatto solo che non li ho mai
fatti in questo contesto con la
ciambella cioè bellico e magari sto
dicendo ciambella dall'inizio ma non è
una ciambella ma so cosa sia ma è una
roba che di sicuro fa schifo per dove
passata che sto facendo questo andando
fermi tutti non devo andare di qua per
dove ho sbagliato strada all'incrocio a
destra dovevo girare un navigatore melo
data la prossima volta magari fatto di
caramelle non so bravo bravissimo
dove vai ma sono partito di qua vabbè ma
[ __ ] il sesso il sesso dal
traguardo giusto ragazzo mio sbaglio
madonna prince of persia sul muro e
carta igienica e a volte la carta
igienica ti salva il culo ma proprio nel
vero senso della parola dove la ricca
per federare tutto sulla vasca da bagno
potrò andare qua anche all'inizio un
minuto e 5 ma mi avrà dato una z ma va
bene uguale
e che poi ragazzi ancora non ho capito
cos'è cosa minchia sta succedendo lì la
stanno volando pezzi di m a caso ma ok è
la papera intanto guarda
vabbè lasciamo perdere ragazzi andiamo
dovrebbe essere l'ultima non mi ricordo
partire da qua sopra la vedo veramente
dura ragazzi questo qua ci ho messo anni
per farlo
vi dico solo questo che dove vado fermi
tutti fermi tutti polizia perfetto però
mi arrivano i messaggi sul telefono come
se io potessi guardare il telefono in un
momento così difficile della mia vita
questo addio bisogna attaccare le
caramelle ma no che già modo di merda
così figuriamoci con le caramelle si
meravigliava bravo vedi perché le
caramelle fa male li mortacci loro che è
bravo e saprò ag pure il vaso di mia
nonna è rotta è stato oggi né da dove
esce però mi fa fare il giro sei volte
l'ho già fatto sto giri ma che voi non
hackett esplodesse il fegato fuori di
mangiare ciambelle dio mio rai bye bye
bye bye bye bravo bravo
madonna ma è tutto qua sopra suo livello
non è perfetto prima da risorto perché
bravo bravo almeno adesso più in basso
di così non posso cadere anche questo
gioco non può cadere più in basso di
così è però quali sono altri significati
bravissimo un minuto e non ci credo non
ci credo ma come ma no io mi do a lipica
ragazzo premuto la w la w ma che cazzo
serve nella vita la w parte farti
sbagliare suoi e brad o mio dio se
pannello e am brad di pannello desktop
che ha passato pannello di aim brad di
pannello desktop negozi fumato qualche
ora da ragazzi concluso quell'episodio è
stato non ha capito che ha parlato alla
fine sono i fantasmi in casa sarà la
charlie ma che cazzo insomma quindi
ragazzi concludo dicendo che per ogni mi
piace vi mettete al video vi prenderà
vita al vostro tosto la vostra ciambella
e vi stupirà i vasi come solito sei
video è piaciuto lascia l'argomento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
noi video trovate la descrizione sono
secoli cities elettrici davano prossimo
vinto dai ragazzi